bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor
técnico de educação na IBM Quantum. Esta é a oitava lição da série e é a última lição da
segunda unidade da série, que trata de algoritmos quânticos. Falamos sobre o modelo de consulta de computação, incluindo algoritmos quânticos
que oferecem vantagens comprovadas sobre algoritmos clássicos dentro desse modelo. Discutimos conceitos fundamentais conectados com
algoritmos quânticos e como podemos medir o custo computacional, e na lição anterior discutimos estimação de fase e o algoritmo de Shor.
Nesta lição vamos discutir o algoritmo de Grover, que oferece uma vantagem quadrática do quântico sobre
algoritmos clássicos para os chamados problemas de busca não estruturada, que vou descrever assim que entrarmos na
lição. Esses são todos tópicos fundamentais sobre algoritmos quânticos. Há outros algoritmos quânticos
bem como paradigmas gerais que unem diferentes algoritmos quânticos e técnicas algorítmicas quânticas, e
se estiveres interessado, te encorajo a conferir o Quantum Algorithm Zoo, que categoriza algoritmos quânticos conhecidos e inclui muitas referências
a artigos de pesquisa originais que contribuíram para seu desenvolvimento. Para esta série, porém,
vamos nos ater apenas aos fundamentos, e a partir da próxima lição vamos passar para um novo tópico. Mas
primeiro vamos falar sobre o algoritmo de Grover. Aqui está a visão geral da lição. Vamos começar com uma curta discussão sobre
o problema computacional que vamos abordar, que é a busca não estruturada. Intuitivamente falando, você pode
pensar sobre o problema de busca não estruturada como buscar em uma coleção de itens que não está ordenada e não foi organizada de uma forma útil.
Em seguida, vamos discutir o algoritmo de Grover, que é um algoritmo quântico que oferece uma vantagem quadrática sobre
algoritmos clássicos, e vamos detalhar o que isso significa em breve. Uma descrição de muito alto nível de
como esse algoritmo funciona é que primeiro há uma etapa de inicialização, e então uma operação que vou chamar de operação
de Grover é iterada um certo número de vezes, e finalmente uma medição ocorre que revela um candidato a
solução para o problema de busca. Vou explicar o que é a operação de Grover e como ela pode ser
implementada em um computador quântico, e então vamos fazer uma análise dessa operação para entender melhor o que ela faz e por que é útil para
busca. A terceira parte da lição está relacionada com o número de iterações
no algoritmo de Grover, ou em outras palavras, o número de vezes que a operação de Grover deve ser aplicada, presumindo que desejamos
maximizar a probabilidade de que o algoritmo tenha sucesso em encontrar o que estamos buscando, ao mesmo tempo minimizando seu
custo. Vamos começar com o problema de busca única, que é um caso especial em que há exatamente uma solução para nosso
problema de busca, e então vamos considerar o que acontece quando há múltiplas soluções. E finalmente, vou concluir a
lição com alguns breves comentários sobre o algoritmo de Grover e suas generalizações. Vamos começar com o
problema computacional que abordaremos ao longo da lição. Primeiro, como muitas vezes fazemos, vamos
deixar Sigma denotar o alfabeto binário, e vamos usar essa notação ao longo de toda a lição, então não vou continuar
te lembrando. Suponha que temos uma função f que mapeia cadeias binárias de algum comprimento n para
o alfabeto binário. Nossa suposição é que podemos avaliar facilmente essa função.
Por exemplo, talvez tenhamos um circuit booleano para essa função cujo tamanho é polinomial em N. Agora isso não significa que isso é
necessariamente uma função simples em qualquer sentido, ou que temos um entendimento particularmente bom dessa função. Por exemplo, talvez tenhamos um
circuit booleano bastante complicado e confuso para calcular f que nos permite avaliá-la em diferentes cadeias de entrada, mas não tem necessariamente uma
forma agradável projetada para facilitar nossa vida. Nosso objetivo é encontrar uma solução, pelo
qual queremos dizer uma cadeia binária de comprimento n que faz f avaliar como um. Em geral, este é um problema
computacional muito difícil, ou pelo menos suspeitamos que seja muito difícil. Em particular, se a entrada é de fato a
descrição de um circuit booleano para calcular a função f, então este é um chamado problema NP-completo. Uma forma
de formalizar esse problema é como um problema de consulta, e de fato para os propósitos desta lição é razoável
pensar sobre esse problema puramente no contexto do modelo de consulta. Mas quando pensamos sobre onde ou quando esse
problema pode surgir na prática, é indiscutivelmente mais natural pensar sobre f como sendo computada por um circuit
booleano. Como vimos na lição seis, porém, podemos conectar esses dois pontos de vista através da construção que fizemos para tomar um circuit booleano e
convertê-lo em um circuit quântico para implementar uma operação de consulta ou um gate de consulta. Em qualquer caso, conceitualmente falando,
a entrada para o problema é essa função f, e estamos procurando uma solução se houver uma. E se não
houver uma solução, o que significa que f acaba sendo a função zero constante, então a saída correta é reportar
que não há soluções. Esse é um problema de busca não estruturada no sentido de que não há
nada de especial em f que facilite a busca por uma solução. Não é como se estivéssemos buscando
em dados que já foram ordenados ou carregados em alguma estrutura de dados que facilita a busca, e não há nenhuma promessa sobre a
função f que nos poderia ajudar. Uma forma de pensar sobre isso é que é como buscar por um
número de telefone específico em uma lista telefônica, em vez de buscar por um nome, o que é muito mais fácil, presumindo que os nomes tenham
sido alfabetizados. Em termos práticos, não é realmente sobre busca em dados
que tendemos a organizar e armazenar de uma maneira que facilita a busca. É mais representativo de buscar por uma
solução para uma equação complicada, por exemplo, ou talvez buscar pela combinação que abre um
cadeado. Como aparte, faz sentido pensar sobre esse problema no contexto do modelo de consulta, independentemente de como podemos
nos sentir sobre a relevância prática desse modelo. Claro, não há oráculos ou caixas-pretas na vida real, mas até
aprendermos o contrário, circuits booleanos complicados e misteriosos são meio que caixas
pretas. Agora vamos pensar sobre algoritmos para resolver esse problema de busca não estruturada, e vamos fazer isso
no modelo de consulta apenas por simplicidade. Se temos um circuit booleano para nossa função em vez de uma caixa preta,
ainda podemos executar algoritmos de consulta nele, mas claro que não podemos descartar a possibilidade de que algum novo algoritmo
seja descoberto para esse problema que não seja baseado em fazer consultas. Mas não vamos nos preocupar com essa
possibilidade. Primeiro, apenas um pouco de notação: o número total de cadeias de entrada para a função f é 2 elevado a
n minúsculo, onde n minúsculo é o comprimento das cadeias de entrada para f, e daqui em diante vou deixar N maiúsculo ser esse número, 2 elevado a
n minúsculo. É bastante comum que as pessoas usem uma letra maiúscula assim para denotar dois elevado à potência da versão minúscula
dessa letra. Vamos falar sobre o número N maiúsculo com frequência, então isso vai ser apenas
conveniente e vai ajudar a manter as coisas um pouco mais organizadas. E novamente, essa notação vale para
toda a lição. Agora, claro que podemos resolver o problema de busca classicamente simplesmente
iterando por todas as possíveis cadeias de n bits em qualquer ordem que escolhermos, avaliando f em cada uma delas.
Se encontrarmos uma solução a qualquer momento podemos parar, mas no pior caso acabaremos avaliando f em cada única
cadeia de entrada. Portanto, isso requer N — ou seja, N maiúsculo —
consultas. Poderíamos escolher medir o custo desta computação de uma forma diferente, não apenas em termos do número de consultas, mas o número de consultas
representa o número de vezes que temos que avaliar a função f, e é razoável esperar que as avaliações de f dominem o custo
desta computação. Isso é de fato o melhor que podemos fazer com um algoritmo determinístico,
e novamente, isso está no contexto do modelo de consulta. Se consultamos cada cadeia de entrada
exceto uma delas, e f tomou o valor zero em todas elas até agora, como podemos ter certeza de que a última
cadeia não é a solução? E a resposta é que não podemos. Então precisamos de todas as N consultas no pior
caso. Também poderíamos usar aleatoriedade, que pode oferecer algumas melhorias muito menores, como reduzir o
número esperado de consultas necessárias para encontrar uma solução quando há uma, ou poderíamos efetivamente trocar a probabilidade de correção
por uma redução nas consultas. Mas como quer que analisemos, ainda vamos precisar de um número de consultas que seja linear
em N. Portanto, classicamente precisamos de um número linear de consultas — linear
em N maiúsculo. O algoritmo de Grover é um algoritmo quântico para busca que faz melhor. Ele requer apenas O de raiz
quadrada de N consultas. Essas consultas acontecem em superposição, então não é mágica, mas
é uma melhoria significativa em relação ao que é possível classicamente, e é isso que se entende por uma vantagem
quadrática. Essa vantagem quadrática do quântico sobre o clássico pode ser transformada em uma vantagem real em um sentido prático?
Provavelmente não tão cedo, mas no futuro distante quem sabe. Mas mesmo que
o algoritmo de Grover nunca leve a uma vantagem prática para busca, é mesmo assim uma parte importante
da fundação dos algoritmos quânticos que vale muito a pena entender. Antes de passarmos para o próprio algoritmo de Grover, precisamos
falar brevemente sobre os chamados gates de consulta de fase. Muitos algoritmos quânticos no modelo de consulta são expressos naturalmente
usando gates de consulta de fase, e veremos que o algoritmo de Grover é um exemplo
específico. Vamos começar com uma visão rápida dos gates de consulta ordinários. Para uma função f da
forma que temos discutido, o gate de consulta UF é definido em estados da base padrão como é mostrado na
tela, e para superposições de estados da base padrão a ação é determinada por linearidade. E vale lembrar
que a partir de um circuit booleano para f podemos de fato construir um circuit para essa operação UF a um custo que é
linear no tamanho do circuit booleano. O gate de consulta de fase para f, por outro lado, que denotaremos pelo
nome ZF, opera assim. Em particular, esse gate opera em
n qubits em vez de n mais um qubits, e basicamente apenas automaticamente envia o valor da função para a fase em vez de fazer XOR do valor de saída para um qubit adicional como temos para
UF. Portanto, se pensarmos sobre o que acontece quando usamos phase kickback em um gate UF,
estamos basicamente apenas implementando um gate ZF. Precisamos de um estado menos e custa uma
avaliação de UF, mas de fato obtemos o estado menos de volta e podemos usá-lo para o próximo se quisermos, ou
podemos simplesmente descartá-lo. Então é isso que é um gate de consulta de fase. Agora, se nos é dado apenas
um gate de consulta de fase ZF e essa é a única forma que temos de acessar a função f, então não podemos de fato
recuperar um gate UF. Mas se tivermos uma versão controlada de ZF então podemos
construir um gate UF, e vou deixar esse para você como um
exercício. Além do gate de consulta de fase para a função f, também vamos precisar de um gate de consulta de fase para a função OR de N bits, ou em outras palavras, a função que toma valor zero quando lhe é dada a cadeia de zeros e caso contrário
toma o valor um. E explicitamente a forma como ZOR funciona em estados da base padrão é mostrada
aqui na tela. Esse gate não tem nenhuma dependência da função f, portanto não requer
nenhuma consulta. E uma forma de construir um circuit quântico que implementa essa operação é fazendo algo
semelhante ao que fizemos para a função f, exceto que começamos com um circuit booleano que calcula a função OR em
N bits. E agora que temos esses gates estamos prontos para passar para a próxima
seção. Agora vamos discutir o algoritmo de Grover, começando com uma descrição do algoritmo. Começamos inicializando
n qubits cada um no estado mais, ou em outras palavras, colocamos esses qubits em uma superposição igual de todas
as cadeias binárias de comprimento n. O que vamos fazer é efetivamente direcionar o estado desses qubits
para uma solução, então é intuitivo que começamos nesse estado porque ainda não sabemos nada sobre a função f.
Nesse ponto, toda cadeia é igualmente provável de ser uma solução, e isso é refletido pelo fato de que esses qubits estão em uma superposição igual de todas
as cadeias. E então iteramos: aplicamos repetidamente a operação de Grover, que é realmente o coração do
algoritmo, e vou descrevê-la em apenas um momento. Aplicamos essa operação um total de T vezes, onde T é algum inteiro não-negativo,
mas esse número não é especificado pelo algoritmo em si. Temos que escolher T de alguma forma, e na próxima
seção vamos falar sobre boas escolhas para T. Mas por ora podemos pensar sobre esse número de iterações T como
sendo arbitrário. E finalmente medimos na base padrão, e isso nos dá um
candidato a solução. Não há garantia de que seja uma solução, mas se escolhermos T bem,
a probabilidade de obter uma solução pode ser tornada grande. E aqui está a operação de Grover
em si, que chamamos de G. É uma composição de operações, todas em N qubits, então esta é uma operação de N
qubits. Primeiro temos um gate ZF, ou em outras palavras um gate de consulta de fase para a
função f de entrada, seguido de uma camada de gates Hadamard, e então temos ZOR, que é o gate de consulta de fase para a função OR, e finalmente outra camada de gates Hadamard. Então vemos que uma iteração na
etapa dois pode ser implementada por um circuit com a forma mostrada aqui na tela, e aqui temos quatro qubits a propósito,
mas em geral podemos ter qualquer número de qubits. Um ponto-chave a notar aqui é que precisamos de uma consulta de f para implementar G;
precisamos de uma consulta para implementar ZF e nenhuma das outras operações tem qualquer dependência em f, então não requerem nenhuma consulta. Portanto, esse número T que
representa o número de vezes que aplicamos G na etapa dois também representa o número de consultas que
precisamos. Aqui está uma forma típica de usarmos o algoritmo de Grover, mas certamente não é a única forma. Como disse
antes, a primeira coisa que precisamos fazer é escolher T, e vamos entrar nisso na próxima seção.
Para qualquer T que escolhemos, executamos o algoritmo de Grover por T iterações e obtemos um candidato a solução
X. Não há garantia de que X seja realmente uma solução, mas podemos gastar uma consulta adicional para verificar. Se temos uma solução, podemos
emitir essa solução e parar, e caso contrário podemos tentar novamente, possivelmente com uma escolha diferente de T
mas não necessariamente, ou podemos desistir e reportar que não há soluções. Como disse antes, essa não é
a única forma de usar o algoritmo, mas essa é uma forma natural de aplicá-lo ao problema de busca. A seguir, vamos ver o que a operação de Grover
realmente faz com o estado dos N qubits sobre os quais ela age. Vamos pensar em nossos N qubits como
formando um único registrador, que vou chamar de Q apenas para dar um nome. Lembre-se de que o que fazemos primeiro no
algoritmo de Grover é colocar Q em uma superposição uniforme de todas as cadeias de n bits, e fazemos isso aplicando gates Hadamard
a N qubits no estado de todos zeros. Em seguida, iteramos a operação de Grover G, e então
medimos. Vai ser útil particionar o conjunto de todas as cadeias de n bits em dois conjuntos, A0 e
A1. A0 contém todas as cadeias que fazem f avaliar como zero, e A1 contém todas as cadeias que fazem f
avaliar como um. Outra forma de dizer isso é que A1 contém todas as soluções para nosso problema de busca
enquanto A0 contém todas as não-soluções. Vamos estar especialmente
interessados em dois estados quânticos: um é a superposição uniforme sobre todas as não-soluções — esse é |A0⟩ — e
o outro é uniforme sobre todas as soluções, e esse é |A1⟩. Devo observar que essas definições só fazem
sentido quando esses conjuntos não estão vazios, porque do contrário estaríamos somando zero elementos e dividindo por zero. E à medida que
fazemos essa análise do algoritmo de Grover, vamos fazer essa suposição. Podemos muito facilmente descobrir o que
o algoritmo de Grover faz quando f é a função zero constante ou a função um constante, tratando-os como casos especiais, mas vou deixar isso
para você fazer por conta própria. Não surpreendentemente, se toda cadeia é uma solução, de fato obteremos uma
solução quando medirmos, e se não houver soluções então não obteremos uma, porque nesse caso não há
nenhuma. Mas para fins desta análise, vamos assumir que ambos os conjuntos são não-vazios para que essas
definições desses dois estados façam sentido. A propósito, essa é uma notação bastante comum:
sempre que temos um conjunto finito não-vazio S, podemos escrever |S⟩ para significar a superposição uniforme sobre os
elementos desse conjunto, assim como temos aqui. Então vamos coletar essas definições assim e veremos como elas se conectam
ao algoritmo de Grover. A primeira etapa do algoritmo de Grover é a etapa de inicialização, que coloca Q em uma superposição uniforme
sobre todas as cadeias de n bits, e só para dar a esse estado um nome facilmente reconhecível, vou chamá-lo de
|u⟩. U é abreviação de uniforme. É importante para fins da análise que primeiro observemos que
esse estado uniforme |u⟩ está contido no subespaço gerado pelos dois vetores |A0⟩ e |A1⟩.
Em particular, se tomarmos a combinação linear desses dois estados que é mostrada aqui na tela, obteremos |u⟩.
Agora, a chave para toda a análise é o fato de que o estado de Q permanece nesse
subespaço bidimensional não importa quantas vezes aplicamos a operação de Grover. Portanto, tudo vai se reduzir a
o que acontece em um subespaço bidimensional. Agora vamos ver o que a operação de Grover faz, e em particular o que ela
faz com vetores no subespaço bidimensional gerado por |A0⟩ e |A1⟩.
É útil imaginar que G é dividida em duas partes: uma parte é o gate ZF
e a outra parte é o gate ZOR entre duas camadas de gates Hadamard.
Aqui está a definição de ZF de antes, e é bastante direto a partir dessa definição ver que sua
ação em nossos dois estados — as superposições uniformes de não-soluções e soluções — é simplesmente colocar um sinal de menos
na frente de |A1⟩. Nada acontece com |A0⟩, e isso é tudo o que realmente precisamos saber
sobre ZF para fins desta análise. Para a segunda parte, que é o
gate ZOR entre duas camadas de gates Hadamard, vamos começar lembrando como ZOR é definido. Uma forma de escrevê-lo
é como é mostrado na tela. Essa é a mesma expressão de antes, e outra forma de expressá-la usando a notação
de produto externo é assim. E você pode verificar essa expressão apenas pensando sobre como a operação no
lado direito age em estados da base padrão. Em particular, ela não faz nada com o estado de todos zeros, e todo
outro estado da base padrão recebe um sinal de menos, o que concorda com a definição de Z
OR. Portanto, se colocarmos essa operação entre duas camadas de gates Hadamard, obtemos uma expressão similar exceto
que em lugar do estado da base padrão de todos zeros agora temos nossa superposição uniforme |u⟩, e isso é porque H tensorial
n transforma o estado da base padrão de todos zeros em |u⟩, e também H tensorial n é seu próprio conjugado transposto, então funciona de
maneira similar agindo da direita no bra em vez do ket. E agora vamos descobrir
o que G faz com nossos dois vetores |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ usando os fatos que acabamos de
observar. Vamos começar com |A0⟩. Primeiro, vamos substituir a expressão
que obtivemos para o gate ZOR entre duas camadas de gates Hadamard. Em seguida, podemos usar o fato de que ZF não faz nada
com |A0⟩, então podemos eliminar a operação ZF. E agora, usando a descrição
de |u⟩ que temos aqui, juntamente com o fato de que |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ são vetores unitários ortogonais, podemos calcular
o produto deste bra aqui e deste ket. E o que obtemos é a raiz quadrada do número de não-soluções
dividida por N. Podemos usar esse fato para avaliar o que obtemos, e substituindo nossa expressão para |u⟩ e
simplificando, obtemos o resultado final mostrado aqui na tela. Em particular, note que este
vetor está contido no subespaço bidimensional gerado por |A0⟩ e |A1⟩, como sugeri antes. E
além disso, os coeficientes acabam sendo números reais. Como sempre, verifique isso no seu
próprio ritmo, se você escolher fazer isso. Costumo passar por esses tipos de coisas rapidamente nesses vídeos com a
expectativa de que você vai pausar o vídeo para pensar sobre isso se quiser. Então vamos limpar isso para que
possamos salvar o resultado final para mais tarde. E agora faremos algo semelhante para o vetor |A1⟩.
Podemos usar a mesma expressão de G de antes, e desta vez o gate ZF injeta
um sinal de menos, que aqui é refletido pelo fato de que trocamos os dois termos na operação entre
parênteses. Em seguida, procedemos de maneira muito similar, e o resultado final é similar exceto que os dois coeficientes
estão trocados e agora temos um sinal de menos na frente de um deles, que é apenas como a álgebra funciona. E novamente, você
pode verificar isso no seu próprio ritmo. Note que mais uma vez temos uma combinação linear real de nossos dois vetores |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. Vamos limpar este também, e vamos juntar o resultado final com o outro. E agora podemos ver como G
age no subespaço gerado por nossos dois vetores. Uma forma de fazer isso é expressá-la em termos da matriz 2x2 M que é
mostrada aqui na tela. E só para deixar claro o que estamos fazendo aqui: estamos associando a primeira linha e a primeira
coluna com |A0⟩ e a segunda linha e coluna com |A1⟩. Até agora na série, realmente
usamos matrizes principalmente para descrever como as operações funcionam em estados da base padrão, mas é comum usar matrizes
para descrever as ações de mapas lineares em diferentes conjuntos de vetores, não apenas estados da base padrão. E aqui estamos falando sobre o que a operação G faz
com os vetores |A0⟩ e |A1⟩. Podemos dizer mais sobre o que G faz com vetores no
espaço gerado por |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ se dermos uma olhada mais de perto nessa matriz M. E em particular, o que vamos encontrar é
que M é uma matriz de rotação, o que significa que sua ação nesse espaço bidimensional pode ser descrita como uma rotação por algum
ângulo fixo. Há algumas formas diferentes de ver isso, e uma delas é observar
que essa matriz M pode ser expressa como o quadrado de uma matriz que parece um pouco mais simples. Pode ser difícil de notar se
apenas olharmos para M sozinha, mas isso não é algo que precisamos descobrir por conta própria — apenas precisamos verificar, e podemos fazer isso simplesmente
elevando ao quadrado a matriz do lado direito. Outra forma de escrever a matriz do lado direito, não incluindo o quadrado, é
mostrada na tela, e essa é a forma típica de descrever uma rotação por um dado ângulo Theta como uma
matriz. O ângulo preciso pelo qual estamos rotacionando é o arco-seno da raiz quadrada do número de
soluções dividido por N. E a propósito, porque é a primeira vez que estamos vendo isso, deixa-me observar que
esse ângulo é muito importante — vai continuar aparecendo conforme prosseguimos com esta
análise. O argumento do arco-seno é um número entre 0 e 1, e especificamente a forma como estamos
interpretando o arco-seno aqui é que é o ângulo entre 0 e Pi/2 que nos dá o argumento quando tomamos o
seno. Então essa é uma forma de pensar sobre essa matriz que elevamos ao quadrado para obter
M. E como elevar ao quadrado a matriz é o mesmo que aplicá-la duas vezes, vemos que M pode alternativamente ser escrita como uma
rotação não por um ângulo de Theta mas por 2 * Theta, porque ao elevar ao quadrado rotacionamos por um ângulo de Theta
duas vezes. Uma forma diferente de verificar tudo isso, a propósito, caso seja útil, é começar com essa expressão final de M
e usar as fórmulas de ângulo duplo da trigonometria para obter a expressão original de
M. E essa é a expressão de M que descreve a ação que G tem no subespaço gerado por |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ que vai
ser mais útil daqui em diante. Agora voltando ao próprio algoritmo de Grover: após a
etapa de inicialização, mas antes de realizarmos quaisquer aplicações de G, o estado de nosso registrador de N qubits Q é |u⟩, a
superposição uniforme sobre todas as cadeias de n bits. E aqui temos a mesma expressão de |u⟩ em termos de |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩ como antes. Mas agora que identificamos esse ângulo Theta, vemos que podemos alternativamente escrever |u⟩ como cosseno de Theta vezes |A0⟩ mais seno de Theta vezes |A1⟩.
Isso está claro para o coeficiente de |A1⟩, e para o outro coeficiente só precisamos observar que o tamanho de A0 mais
o tamanho de A1 é N, e então podemos obtê-lo a partir de trigonometria básica. Então esse é o estado com que
começamos, e a primeira vez que aplicamos G, rotacionamos por um ângulo de 2 * Theta, então o ângulo total se torna 3 *
Theta. E se aplicarmos G novamente, o ângulo aumenta para 5 Theta, porque efetivamente rotacionamos por um adicional
de 2 Theta. E assim por diante. Portanto, após T aplicações de G, podemos representar o
estado que obtemos como é mostrado na tela, onde o ângulo de nosso estado é igual a 2T + 1 vezes Theta. São 2 * Theta
para cada aplicação de G junto com um Theta adicional porque esse é o estado com que começamos.
Também podemos pensar sobre a ação da operação de Grover em termos geométricos, e isso ajuda a esclarecer como
ela funciona e por que seu efeito é rotacionar o estado do registrador Q. Aqui está a ideia principal: a operação de Grover
é uma composição das duas partes que já identificamos. Uma é ZF e a outra é ZOR entre
duas camadas de gates Hadamard. Essas duas partes são
reflexões, e quando compusemos duas reflexões obtemos uma rotação. Então vamos ver como isso funciona em
mais detalhes. Primeiro, vamos focar em ZF, e vamos restringir nossa atenção ao
mesmo subespaço bidimensional que temos discutido, ou seja, aquele que é gerado por |A0⟩ e |A1⟩.
Como já observamos, a ação de ZF nesse espaço é bastante simples: ela não faz nada
com |A0⟩ e coloca um sinal de menos na frente de |A1⟩. Isso é uma reflexão, e especificamente
é uma reflexão sobre a linha paralela a |A0⟩, que chamaremos de L1 só para dar um nome.
Para ver por que é uma reflexão, ajuda desenhar um quadro. Aqui temos nossos dois vetores |A0⟩
e |A1⟩, que são vetores unitários ortogonais, e podemos pensar na tela como consistindo de todas as
combinações lineares reais desses dois vetores. Portanto, o círculo representa todos os vetores unitários para os quais os coeficientes de
esses dois vetores são números reais. Aqui está a linha L1, que é paralela a |A0⟩. E se considerarmos algum
vetor arbitrário s nesse círculo, então o efeito de aplicar ZF é refletir sobre essa linha, como é ilustrado na
tela, simplesmente porque não fazemos nada com |A0⟩ e colocamos um sinal de menos na frente de |A1⟩.
No caso especial em que s é |A0⟩, por exemplo, nada acontece quando realizamos essa reflexão. E quando s é
|A1⟩, a reflexão nos leva até |A1⟩ negativo, e isso é consistente com a ação de ZF. Portanto, ZF é uma
reflexão que pode ser visualizada como temos aqui. A segunda parte de G, que é ZOR
entre duas camadas de gates Hadamard, pode ser expressa como 2 * |u⟩⟨u| menos a matriz identidade, como já
vimos. E novamente, isso é uma reflexão, desta vez sobre a linha L2 paralela a |u⟩ em vez de |A0⟩.
Podemos visualizar essa operação de maneira semelhante a ZF. Aqui está o vetor |u⟩
hipoteticamente, então essa é a linha L2 paralela a |u⟩, e mais uma vez a ação em um vetor arbitrário s é refletir
sobre a linha, que é L2 neste caso.
E finalmente, como mencionei antes, sempre que compomos duas reflexões obtemos uma rotação, e especificamente é
uma rotação pelo dobro do ângulo entre as linhas de reflexão. Então vamos desenhar um
quadro semelhante ao que tínhamos antes. Aqui estão as linhas de reflexão, que têm o ângulo Theta entre
elas. E se tomarmos algum vetor arbitrário s, refletirmos sobre a primeira linha L1 e
depois refletirmos sobre a segunda linha L2, o efeito líquido será rotacionar o vetor s por um ângulo de 2 Theta.
E isso é algo que é verdadeiro em geral, e você pode tentar com alguns exemplos adicionais por conta própria para ver que de fato é assim que
funciona. De qualquer forma, esperançosamente isso te ajuda a ter alguma intuição sobre por que a operação de Grover tem o efeito de rotacionar
vetores. A seguir, vamos abordar a questão de escolher o número de iterações T no algoritmo de
Grover. Vamos começar pensando sobre como a análise que vimos até agora — que revela o que a operação de Grover faz
quando a aplicamos repetidamente à superposição uniforme — se relaciona com a tarefa que esperamos resolver, que é encontrar uma solução para nosso problema de busca,
ou em outras palavras, qualquer cadeia contida no conjunto A1. Em resumo, vamos basicamente definir
um alvo e então descobrir quantas vezes aplicar a operação de Grover para chegar perto desse
alvo. Primeiro, vamos imaginar que temos qualquer estado que é uma combinação linear de nossos dois vetores |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. Se realizarmos uma medição na base padrão nesse estado, obteremos um resultado no conjunto A1, que é
o conjunto de soluções para nosso problema de busca, com probabilidade igual ao valor absoluto ao quadrado de qualquer coeficiente que tenhamos para |A1⟩. E para o
vetor que é mostrado na tela, esse coeficiente é beta. Isso é intuitivo: se medíssemos o estado |A0⟩
obteríamos uma não-solução aleatória, e se medíssemos |A1⟩ obteríamos uma solução aleatória. Então se medirmos este estado
aqui, obteremos uma não-solução aleatória com probabilidade valor absoluto de alpha ao quadrado e uma solução aleatória
com probabilidade valor absoluto de beta ao quadrado. Mas também podemos apenas tomar um momento para trabalhar isso. Aqui está o estado escrito
para que possamos ver quais são as entradas desse vetor para estados da base padrão. Portanto, se medirmos, estas são as
probabilidades de obter cada resultado possível. E para obter a probabilidade de obter uma solução, somamos as
probabilidades para todas as soluções possíveis, o que nos dá o valor absoluto de beta ao quadrado como
esperado. Agora, já analisamos o que acontece quando executamos o algoritmo de Grover por T iterações. Obtemos o estado que é
mostrado aqui na tela. Portanto, como o coeficiente de |A1⟩ é o seno
de 2T + 1 vezes Theta — onde mais uma vez está esse ângulo muito importante Theta — vamos
ver uma solução com probabilidade seno ao quadrado de 2T + 1 vezes
Theta. Gostaríamos de tornar essa probabilidade grande, idealmente o mais próximo de um possível. Então, à medida que estamos rotacionando o vetor de estado
iterando G, vamos pensar em |A1⟩ como o estado alvo e vamos tentar
escolher T de modo a pousar próximo a esse estado. E à medida que fazemos isso, é bom ter em mente que também gostaríamos de
minimizar T porque esse é o número de consultas que precisamos fazer. Então se queremos tornar essa
probabilidade próxima de um e minimizar T, faz sentido tentar tornar o ângulo de nosso vetor de estado próximo de Pi/2, porque
esse é o menor ângulo que torna o quadrado do seno grande. Então é basicamente nossa primeira oportunidade de tornar a probabilidade grande à medida que estamos
rotacionando o vetor de estado. Agora não podemos necessariamente acertar esse ângulo Pi/2 exatamente porque T tem que
ser um inteiro, mas se pensarmos sobre isso aproximadamente e resolvermos para T como se fosse uma igualdade, então vemos que idealmente
escolher T como Pi dividido por 4 vezes Theta menos 1/2 faz
sentido. Mas é claro que T deve ser um inteiro não-negativo, então o que faremos é
tomar o inteiro mais próximo do que imaginamos ser esse valor ideal, que é o piso de Pi dividido por 4 vezes
Theta. Tomar o piso, a propósito, significa simplesmente descartar qualquer parte fracionária, ou em outras palavras, é o maior
inteiro que é menor ou igual a qualquer coisa que estamos tomando o piso. Segundo essa expressão, se o
valor ideal for exatamente a meio caminho entre inteiros, arredondaremos para cima, mas isso não vai importar em nada para os
fins desta lição. Portanto, daqui em diante vamos nos concentrar nessa escolha específica de
T. Mas há uma outra consideração importante que precisamos fazer, que é que essa especificação de T depende
de quantas soluções há, porque o ângulo Theta depende do número de
soluções. Daqui em diante vou usar a letra s para me referir ao número de soluções, ou em outras palavras, o tamanho do
conjunto A1, apenas por conveniência. De qualquer forma, o ponto é que nossa
T, mas há uma outra consideração importante que precisamos fazer, que é que esta especificação de T depende
de quantas soluções existem, porque o ângulo Theta depende do número de
soluções. Daqui em diante vou usar a letra s para me referir ao número de soluções, ou em outras palavras, ao tamanho do
conjunto A1, apenas por conveniência. De qualquer forma, o ponto é que nossa
expressão para T — o valor que estamos hipotetizando que deve ser bom — depende de Theta, e Theta depende de s, que é
o tamanho do conjunto A1. Isso não é um problema se soubermos de antemão quantas soluções há, mas
se não soubermos quantas soluções há de antemão, não sabemos o que é Theta, então não podemos escolher T assim.
E teremos que fazer algo diferente. Voltarei à situação em que não sabemos s um pouco mais tarde, mas para
começar, vamos focar na situação em que sabemos quantas soluções há, começando com busca única,
onde é garantido que há uma única solução que estamos
procurando. Mencionei o problema de busca única como um exemplo de um problema de consulta na lição
cinco. A entrada é uma função f de n bits para um bit. Há uma única cadeia de n bits
que faz f avaliar como um, e o objetivo é emitir essa cadeia. Portanto,
isso é equivalente ao problema de busca não estruturada que temos discutido, mas com a promessa de que há exatamente uma solução. E de fato essa é
a única versão do problema de busca que Lov Grover considerou em seu artigo original de 1996 que introduziu o algoritmo de Grover.
Para busca única, temos que s é igual a 1, e portanto esse ângulo importante Theta é igual ao arco-seno
da raiz quadrada de 1/N. Quando N é grande, esse valor é aproximadamente a raiz quadrada de 1/N, e
isso porque para ângulos cada vez menores, a função seno começa a parecer cada vez mais com a função
identidade. Se substituirmos essa aproximação em nossa seleção para T, vemos que T é aproximadamente o piso
de Pi dividido por 4 vezes a raiz quadrada de N. Isso é bom porque estamos no caminho de usar O de raiz quadrada de N
consultas, embora nesse ponto ainda não tenhamos dado uma olhada em exatamente quão bem o algoritmo
funciona. Vamos dar uma olhada em um exemplo onde N maiúsculo é 128, que é 2 elevado a 7. Portanto,
nossa função f é de sete bits para um bit, e estamos assumindo que há uma solução única. Mas para descobrir quão
bem o algoritmo funciona, realmente só precisamos nos preocupar com o ângulo Theta, que podemos calcular. É
aproximadamente 0,0885 radianos, que é um pouco mais de 5°. E se plugarmos esse valor em nossa
expressão para T, obtemos oito. Então estamos pensando sobre o que acontece quando buscamos por uma solução única dentre 128
possibilidades usando oito consultas. Podemos desenhar um quadro para ilustrar como o estado muda ao longo do
tempo à medida que realizamos iterações da operação de Grover. Como antes, temos os estados
|A0⟩ e |A1⟩, e nesse caso específico — busca única — temos que |A1⟩ é de fato o estado da base padrão
correspondente à solução única, seja lá qual for. Bem, |A0⟩ é a superposição uniforme sobre todas
as cadeias além da solução única. Aqui está a superposição uniforme sobre todas as cadeias, que podemos
escrever como cosseno de Theta vezes |A0⟩ mais seno de Theta vezes |A1⟩. E faz sentido que |A0⟩
e |u⟩ sejam próximos nesse caso, porque como acabamos de observar um momento atrás, |A0⟩ é
quase a superposição uniforme sobre todas as cadeias — falta apenas uma cadeia, que é a solução única. Aplicar G novamente rotaciona por um
adicional de 2 Theta, então é aqui que estamos após duas iterações. Aqui está três, quatro, cinco, seis, sete e oito.
E agora vemos que estamos bastante próximos de |A1⟩. Então se pararmos e medirmos nesse ponto, teremos uma boa probabilidade de obter
a solução única. E de fato, nesse caso há apenas cerca de meio por cento de chance de não obtermos a solução única.
Por outro lado, se continuássemos aplicando a operação de Grover mais do que as oito vezes recomendadas,
a probabilidade de obter uma solução voltaria a diminuir, e ao longo do tempo oscilaria à medida que o estado gira
pelo círculo. Portanto, é importante que paremos as iterações no momento certo se quisermos ter sucesso com alta
probabilidade. Vamos pensar sobre a probabilidade de que nossa escolha de T revele a solução única de forma mais geral para diferentes valores de
N. Vamos escrever P(N,1) para denotar a probabilidade de que o algoritmo de Grover tenha sucesso em encontrar uma solução única
para cada valor possível de N. O um significa uma solução, e vamos estender essa notação para outros números de soluções
em breve. Aqui está uma tabela dessas probabilidades para pequenas potências de dois. Começa com N igual a 2 e a
probabilidade é 1/2, o que não é muito bom. Mas então para N igual a 4, a probabilidade é exatamente um, então funciona
perfeitamente nesse caso. É um ótimo exercício, a propósito, percorrer explicitamente como esses dois casos funcionam,
particularmente o caso em que N é igual a quatro. Nesse caso, estamos buscando por uma solução dentre quatro possibilidades.
Precisamos de apenas uma única consulta e funciona perfeitamente. À medida que N fica maior, vemos algumas flutuações — as probabilidades sobem
e descem um pouco — mas elas parecem estar se aproximando de um, e de fato isso é verdade. Pode ser provado
analiticamente que a probabilidade é sempre pelo menos 1 - 1/N. Portanto, isso é bom.
O algoritmo não é perfeito — não temos garantia de obter uma solução — mas é bastante provável, particularmente para grandes
valores de N, bem como a anomalia muito interessante que acontece quando N é igual a 4.
Devo também observar que sempre podemos executar o algoritmo inteiro incluindo as medições quantas vezes escolhermos, e se qualquer uma das execuções
tiver sucesso, obteremos uma solução. Portanto, se essas probabilidades não forem boas o suficiente, podemos facilmente aumentá-las apenas executando
o algoritmo novamente. Na verdade, mesmo que essas probabilidades fossem todas iguais a 1/2, por exemplo, ainda teríamos um
algoritmo de busca útil. Agora vamos considerar o que acontece quando há múltiplas
soluções. Vamos começar com um exemplo semelhante ao de antes. Novamente N é igual a 128, mas desta vez o
número de soluções s é quatro em vez de um. Novamente podemos calcular Theta e T, e
obtemos que Theta é cerca de 0,1777, ou um pouco mais de 10°, e T é
quatro desta vez. Portanto, o ângulo é cerca do dobro do valor do exemplo anterior, e T é metade do que
era. Podemos desenhar um quadro como antes. Aqui está onde
começamos. Aqui está uma iteração, duas, três e quatro. Desta vez estamos muito próximos de |A1⟩,
e a probabilidade de obter uma solução desta vez é maior do que
99,9%. Mas se não soubéssemos melhor e pensássemos que havia apenas uma solução, tomaríamos T como 8 como
antes, rotacionaríamos quase todo o caminho até |A0⟩ negativo, e isso levaria a uma probabilidade de
sucesso muito pequena. Portanto, esse é mais um exemplo mostrando que há boas e más escolhas de T, e aqui vemos
que uma boa escolha para s igual a 1 acaba sendo uma escolha muito ruim para s igual a 4. Mas assumindo que de fato sabemos s com
antecedência e escolhemos T de acordo com nossa especificação, então acaba que o algoritmo de Grover vai encontrar uma solução
com probabilidade pelo menos 1 - s/N, e muitas vezes será bem maior do que isso. Também é pelo menos s/N, mas
isso é de fato muito menos interessante. O que é mais interessante é que à medida que a fração s/N fica pequena, o limite
na probabilidade de sucesso fica cada vez mais próximo de um. Agora, como já remarquei várias
vezes, o número T representa não apenas o número de iterações da operação de Grover que realizamos, mas também o número
de consultas que estamos fazendo. Então como esse número depende de s e
N? Primeiro, vamos começar com o fato de que o arco-seno de x é sempre pelo menos x, desde que x esteja entre 0 e 1.
Isso é bastante fácil de mostrar se você conhece a série de Taylor para a função arco-seno, mas há outras formas de raciocinar, e vamos simplesmente
tomar isso como dado porque é verdade. Isso significa que Theta é pelo menos a raiz quadrada de s/N,
e consequentemente T é no máximo Pi/4 vezes a raiz quadrada de N/s.
Portanto, isso é de fato ainda melhor do que O de raiz de N. Quanto maior for s em
comparação com N, menos consultas precisamos fazer. E de certa forma não é surpreendente que essa fração apareça
assim, dado que seu recíproco define Theta e no fim das contas Theta é realmente tudo que importa para
esta análise. Como acabamos de ver, o algoritmo de Grover funciona muito bem quando sabemos
de antemão quantas soluções há. Mas e se não soubermos quantas soluções
há? Há uma abordagem bastante simples, que é simplesmente escolher o número de iterações
aleatoriamente. E especificamente, escolher T uniformemente ao acaso entre 1 e o piso de Pi/4 vezes raiz de N acaba sendo
uma boa forma de fazer isso. O limite superior desse intervalo é aproximadamente o número de consultas que escolheríamos para busca única, e de fato é
exatamente o número certo na maioria dos casos. Isso é quando o ângulo Theta é tão pequeno quanto pode possivelmente ser, excluindo
o caso trivial quando não há soluções. A ideia aqui é que, em vez de cuidadosamente apontar nosso vetor de estado em
direção a |A1⟩ como fizemos quando sabíamos quantas soluções havia, estamos basicamente rotacionando por um ângulo aleatório, como se estivéssemos
dando um giro aleatório ao vetor de estado. Se por acaso houver apenas uma solução, nosso giro aleatório pode empurrar
o vetor de estado próximo a |A1⟩, mas também pode apenas ir parte do caminho. E se por acaso houver muitas soluções, então
nosso giro aleatório poderia potencialmente enviar o vetor de estado ao redor do círculo múltiplas vezes. Portanto, não esperamos que isso revele
uma solução com probabilidade próxima de um, mas a chance de que isso leve a uma solução se houver uma acaba sendo
bastante boa. É sempre pelo menos 40%, na verdade. Isso não é óbvio, mas é o
caso. Certamente não é chocante, porém, porque um ângulo verdadeiramente aleatório teria uma chance de 50% de encontrar uma
solução. De qualquer forma, 40% não é ruim, e lembre-se de que sempre podemos aumentar a probabilidade de encontrar uma solução
repetindo o processo, escolhendo T independentemente cada vez. Fazendo isso, as chances de não
encontrar uma solução quando há uma diminuem exponencialmente no número de vezes que repetimos. Então se quisermos 99% de
chance de encontrar uma solução, o que podemos fazer é executar essa abordagem simples 10 vezes, novamente com T escolhido independentemente cada
vez. Naturalmente, se não encontrarmos uma solução, emitimos "sem soluções". Se não há soluções,
não vamos encontrar uma, e portanto nesse caso sempre emitiremos a resposta correta, que é "sem soluções". Se há soluções, podemos
não conseguir encontrar uma e incorretamente declarar que não há soluções, mas a probabilidade disso acontecer pode ser tornada muito pequena.
Também temos, como mencionei há alguns momentos, que isso requer um número de consultas ou avaliações de f que é O de raiz
de N. Portanto, usando o algoritmo de Grover ainda podemos resolver o problema de busca com alta probabilidade com O de raiz de N
consultas, mesmo que não saibamos de antemão quantas soluções há. Há também uma abordagem mais sofisticada
que pode levar a uma redução no número de consultas à medida que o número de soluções cresce. Não vou descrevê-la em
detalhes, mas em vez disso vou me concentrar apenas na ideia principal. Começamos com T maiúsculo igual
a um. Em seguida, executamos o algoritmo de Grover por um número aleatório de iterações, mas onde o limite superior é T. Portanto, a primeira
vez que chegamos à etapa dois, vamos executar o algoritmo de Grover com uma iteração, mas T vai estar
crescendo. Se encontrarmos uma solução, emitimos essa solução e paramos. E se não encontrarmos uma solução, tornamos T
maior e tentamos novamente. E em algum momento antes de T ficar muito grande, vamos terminar o processo e
declarar que não há soluções. É a mesma ideia básica que temos na abordagem simples, onde estamos
essencialmente dando giros aleatórios ao vetor de estado, mas aqui começamos com giros mais leves primeiro, quando T é
pequeno, apenas no caso de haver muitas soluções. Dessa forma, não vamos desperdiçar consultas fazendo o estado girar
e girar pelo círculo girando muito forte. Mas se não funcionar — o que significa que não encontramos uma solução — tentamos novamente,
mas giramos um pouco mais forte, ou potencialmente um pouco mais forte. Para fazer isso funcionar, a taxa de
aumento de T precisa ser escolhida cuidadosamente, e uma forma de fazer funcionar é substituir T pelo teto de 5/4 vezes T.
Portanto, T está crescendo exponencialmente, e intuitivamente podemos pensar nisso como girar 25% mais forte a cada
vez. E é importante para a análise que T cresça exponencialmente assim. Por que 5/4? Você pode perguntar. Bem, é
apenas um número que funciona, e há de fato um intervalo de valores que funcionam, mas dois não funciona — por exemplo, dobrar T
a cada vez é um aumento muito rápido para aproveitar totalmente os benefícios dos giros mais leves. De qualquer forma, o ponto dessa abordagem mais
sofisticada é que ela dá o mesmo limite assintótico no número de consultas que exigimos, como tínhamos antes:
O de raiz quadrada de N/s. Mas não precisamos saber de antemão quantas soluções há. E a propósito,
podemos parar esse processo quando T chegar a raiz de N. Portanto, se não houver soluções, vamos chegar a essa conclusão após O de
raiz de N consultas. E é assim que podemos escolher o número de iterações no algoritmo de Grover. Para concluir a lição, vou
fazer apenas alguns breves comentários sobre o algoritmo de Grover. Primeiro, dentro do modelo de consulta,
o algoritmo de Grover é assintoticamente ótimo. O que isso significa é que não é possível criar um
algoritmo de consulta para resolver o problema de busca ou mesmo o problema de busca única especificamente que use assintoticamente
menos de O de raiz de N consultas no pior caso. Isso é algo que pode ser provado rigorosamente,
e de fato existem múltiplas provas conhecidas desse fato. Curiosamente, isso era conhecido
mesmo antes do algoritmo de Grover ser descoberto. O algoritmo de Grover igualou o limite inferior já conhecido sobre o número de
consultas exigidas. De vez em quando as pessoas apresentam abordagens que acreditam ser assintoticamente
superiores ao algoritmo de Grover, mas sempre há um erro ou uma suposição sobre a função f e
como ela pode ser acessada, ou algum outro problema que torna a afirmação incorreta. Se estiveres trabalhando corretamente
dentro do modelo de consulta, não dá para superar o algoritmo de Grover para busca não estruturada. Segundo, o algoritmo de Grover é
bastante amplamente aplicável no sentido de que a aceleração quadrática que o algoritmo de Grover oferece para o problema de busca não estruturada pode ser
obtida em uma variedade de contextos diferentes. Por exemplo, às vezes é possível usar o algoritmo de Grover em
cima de outro algoritmo para obter uma melhoria quadrática além do desempenho daquele algoritmo. O algoritmo de Grover também é
bastante comumente usado como uma sub-rotina dentro de outros algoritmos quânticos. Como apenas um exemplo simples,
podemos usar o algoritmo de Grover para obter uma vantagem quadrática sobre algoritmos clássicos para o problema de mínimo que mencionei na
lição cinco. E finalmente, a técnica usada no algoritmo de Grover, onde temos duas
reflexões que são compostas e iteradas para rotacionar um vetor de estado quântico, pode ser generalizada de uma forma bastante
significativa. Um exemplo é uma técnica conhecida como amplificação de amplitude, onde um processo
que generaliza o algoritmo de Grover pode ser aplicado a outro algoritmo quântico para essencialmente aumentar sua probabilidade de sucesso quadraticamente mais rápido do que
seria possível classicamente. E essa técnica tem amplas aplicações em algoritmos quânticos. Portanto, pode ser verdade que
o algoritmo de Grover provavelmente não levará a uma vantagem quântica prática tão cedo, se alguma vez. Mas o algoritmo de Grover é
sem dúvida um algoritmo quântico fundamentalmente importante e amplamente aplicável, e é representativo de uma técnica mais geral que tem muitos
usos. E é isso para esta lição e para esta unidade da série, que foi sobre algoritmos
quânticos. Discutimos o modelo de consulta e como podemos conectá-lo a um modelo de computação mais padrão, junto com
alguns outros conceitos fundamentais sobre como podemos medir o custo computacional. Em seguida, abordamos estimação de fase,
fatoração e, finalmente, o algoritmo de Grover. Como já sugeri,
há muito mais para aprender sobre algoritmos quânticos, mas nesta série vamos passar para um tópico diferente na próxima unidade. Em particular, vamos dar uma
olhada na formulação geral da informação quântica, onde estados quânticos são representados por matrizes de um certo
tipo, conhecidas como matrizes de densidade. Como veremos, essa formulação acaba sendo muito útil e de fato
essencial para entender alguns aspectos da informação quântica, e também acaba sendo bastante bela do ponto de vista
matemático. Então espero que você se junte a mim na unidade três, e até
lá!